ce vendredi l'arrêt d'hugo labé dans le
bureau des patrons des bains ont regardé
banny lui avec romane polanski et
harrison ford au web
harrison comment va tomber ça va mais
qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé c'est lui est
en colère après toi non on a fait
quelques quelques scènes
j'étais pas très content des scènes de
bagarre l'acteur mama abîmé avec son
couteau il m'a coupé
quelle prise c'était c'était la première
le dic sait rien il veut être cool mais
il aurait pu perdre son nez c'était 1 2
mm non salut à percer la peau perd
maintenant est-ce qu'il a pleuré j'ai
pleuré
le héron à pleurer en fait il était très
très très
je vais pas de romane à recréer les
bains pour frente grand tu te sentais
aubin complètement tout le monde était
là
on a vraiment envie de la caisse tu
penses de romane comme réalisateur je
dois sortir
non non pas au milieu de la pièce
il s'occupe bien des acteurs il est très
sensible que là parce que c'est un bon
acteur bing s'est toujours très bien ce
qu'il veut cette fois je le vois c'est
vraiment un plaisir de bosser avec lui
en fera peut-être mais peut-être qu'il
fera pas comment tu as trouvé harrison
ford comme acteur vraiment maintenant
surtout le niveau humain pas un
particulier et professionnel vraiment
très très sérieux toujours là jamais en
retard une patiente incroyable mais vrai
plaisir de travailler avec ce mec
les rôles qu'ils avaient dans dans la
guerre des étoiles ou dans l'indiana
jones se déroule un peu comique quand
même acquis les sociétés exactement une
certaine réserve tu vois tu tues tu
joues pas tu n'es pas vraiment le
personnage du jour avec tu es toujours
élégant enfin riz
peux tu arrivé là il joue d un rôle ou
êtes vulnérables c'est intrigant
d'acteurs vraiment quelqu'un avec qui on
a un grand plaisir de travailler
ok qu'est ce que tu penses de lui comme
acteur tu l'as vu sur scène oui j'ai vu
la métamorphose c'est fantastique c'est
une grande performance mais cela me fait
me rendre compte à quel point c'est
difficile
les films c'est facile la télévision
c'est rien sa chance est rien les
travailler sur scène pendant une heure
et demie faire ce qui fait tu sais c'est
pas vrai le cinéma c'est très difficile
tu vas tu parles un mec qui vient
d'avoir son sa paupière percée avec un
couteau de les vues du zèle et il a eu
des accidents terribles avec des
explosions sous l'eau qui s'est mal
passé tout et il a des problèmes avec le
genou avec d'autres trucs et difficile
qu'est ce qui veut bien dire
c'est beaucoup plus difficile cela
demande beaucoup de patience je sais pas
si je te raconte l histoire de la douche
on tournait une scène dans la douche
propos frantic et sa durée sa durée mais
à un moment il disait son tube ce cochon
je ne sais même pas ce qui s'est passé
c'est pourquoi tu parles vous il parce
que l'eau est froide roh s'est pas
aperçu que depuis de plus depuis un
cancer ou une demi heure l'eau était
gelée mais vraiment très froid les
visées rien tu vois que c'est quand même
fantastique
c'est fantastique
tu vas jouer sur scène j'ai pas ce genre
d'ambition
j'aime faire des films et j'apprécie
trop le temps que j'ai en dehors de mon
boulot pour faire ce genre de truc ça et
puis tu sais pour travailler sur scène
fait à new york ou à los angeles
je ne préfère pas quand tu joues dans un
film tu vas être très impliquée dans
l'écriture du film intéresse il a des
bonnes idées avec certaines personnes
j'ai l'opportunité de dire ce que je
pense c'est tout
si j'ai une bonne relation avec le
réalisateur mais son aide est énorme sur
le fait vraiment je pense qu'il devrait
diriger les filles il a une idée
complète du film la continuité du jeu ça
peut vous sembler un peu qu'on s'envoie
des fleurs mais des gens avec qui j'ai
fait des films que je pouvais plus
supporter la plupart de l'insead
je dois dire j'ai vraiment beaucoup de
plaisir
tu veux diriger un film sera je pense
que c'est trop dur pour tenter une
approche très mécanique de ton boulot si
j'ai mis la machine en margé parfait
contrôle de la machine
en fait tu es un manuel quoi c'est comme
quand tu coupe du bois dans ton ranch
mais finalement faire un film c'est
pareil c'est un processus logique situe
le jeu construit quelque chose pour un
rôle mais je pense pas qu'ils aient
effectivement beaucoup de mystères d'en
faire des films jours il faut avoir une
capacité visuelle
enfin moi moi je pense aux films en
fonction de mon personnage si tu veux
mais tu sais dirigé des films c'est trop
dur c'est trop long il faut avoir
l'argent ça prend beaucoup de temps pour
monter la faire ça dure un an et demi
moi ça dure cinq mois quand je joue et
là je vous retourne à ma vie c'est pas
seulement mon rôle
l'astuce est trop précieux pour moi tout
ça what they do and you're not
mais qu'est ce tu fais quand tu bosses
pas il coupe du bois du bois j'aurais
par des barrières
je vis je passe mon temps à expliquer ça
aux gens les gens disent mais ça tu vas
jeudi de la wii c'est la vie ça suffit
c'est bien j'ai des enfants une femme
j'aime bien leur donner du temps et en
dehors du boulot ce qui concerne le
temps à moi-même
harrison tu as joué dans cinq des dix
plus grands moneymaker de l'histoire du
cinéma
j'ai tout fait moi même bien ce qu'est
ce t'as fait tout ce pognon
qu'est-ce que j'en ai fait jeter de nos
orphelins la gelée donner aux gens qui
en avaient besoin
enfin soyons sérieux
mais ça c'est un mythe mais c'est pas
lui qui a eu le pognon c'est les studios
il en a une non ce n'est pas la majorité
et pourtant il y en a un paquet
vrai paquet ton avis ils ont ramassé
combien des films pas la moindre idée
tout c'est star wars et indiana jones et
des millions de dollars mais les gens me
demandent toujours ce genre de questions
ça n'a aucune influence sur ma vie ça
n'a pas d'importance je suis très
content que certains films que j'ai
faits et fait beaucoup d'argent ça veut
dire que plein de gens sont allés les
voir ça c'est pas mal mais j'en ai fait
dix autres pour que jamais faire encore
c'est pas que j'ai une touche de midas
j'ai eu du pot et j'ai travaillé des
gens bien mais ça a pris tellement
longtemps pour arriver
ça m'a pris plus de 25 ans comment tu
fais pour résister aux filles il pris 45
ans il ya longtemps que je suis plus
cinglé est vachement sage mais résiste
pas moi je l'admiré parce que des fois
il ya des filles à côté de lui dans les
boîtes il est toujours vachement sérieux
il est sérieux les risques il est
vraiment comme l'image qu'il veut donner
est-ce que c'est seulement visionnage ne
veut pas de données d'image il se soucie
pas de l'image
il donne très rarement des interviews
comme tu le sais ils n'aiment pas ça il
il n'aime pas être dans la lumière de la
rampe et la saison il aime sa femme et
baby est ce que je peux avoir six copies
de l'émission l'accès aux villes saintes
on verra des cassettes mais une pomme
affamés ne provenait pas d'une promo
nouveaux cas
[Rires]
la mère était juive non juifs
mon père était irlandais mois
enfin tu sais que si ta mère est juive
tu es juive ou bien si tu te sens juifs
des fois oui on nettoie on m'a
d'ailleurs fait juste ben oui je suis
juif mais certaines fois tu te sentais
pas après juifs que l'autre oui des fois
quand ma famille m'invite pour certaines
fêtes ya une espèce d'ambiance comme ça
mais c'est le seul moment parce que moi
j'ai été élevé catholique
et puis ma famille a été dispersée
exterminés dans les camps par les nazis
j'ai vraiment pas eu le temps de de
juifs
[Musique]
alors y est oui oui oui oui et oui je
note c'est frédéric mitterrand oui et 10
autres en soi non oui elle peut monter
si le chat et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou